[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo è il correre correre
ecco il riassunto della giornata di oggi
della giornata di ieri l'altro ieri
ecco cosa farò domani dopodomani tra tre
giorni correre correre e soltanto
correre correre mi fa sentire padrone
del tempo un tempo che ha reso fluido
morbido e malleabile modellabile un
tempo che posso stringere tra le mani
infatti attraverso la mia cinica tabella
di marcia porto termine un'iniezione nel
modo migliore
ottimizzando arrivando sempre al
traguardo
sono proprio queste l'esclamazione che
sento ripetere sempre più spesso nei
dialoghi dei nostri giorni
devo correre di qua devo correre di là
la nostra vita è una frettolosa corsa
alla ricerca di un traguardo ma mi
chiedo qual è il traguardo a cui
dobbiamo arrivare al traguardo a cui
vogliamo che la nostra corsa ci porti
evidente vogliamo arrivare al futuro a
un brillante futuro all'innovazione al
progresso scrivere l'alfabeto del futuro
eppure le volte questo punto d'arrivo mi
sembra non esser ben chiaro alle volte
nella mia corsa quotidiana senza tregua
mi capita di sentirmi smarrito di
smarrire il senso di ciò che faccio e da
questa si arresta
è come se terminasse della benzina è
questo ciò che rischiamo tutti tutti che
non funzioni di edificare il nostro
domani
rischiamo di rimanere intrappolati nella
complessità del presente e diventa
impossibile progredire allora stavo
pensando
se vogliamo costruire e se scrivere il
nostro alfabeto del futuro
forse dovremmo tener conto di una
caratteristica dell'alfabeto l'alfabeto
è una sequenza prima c'era poi c'è la b
lapsi l'a.d
quindi l'alfabeto impone un ordine e
come possiamo noi scrivere l'alfabeto
del futuro se non diamo quest'ordine non
sarebbe un alfabeto prendiamola da
un'altra prospettiva essere alle volte
mi capita di immaginare il futuro come
qualcosa che dobbiamo tessere mi capita
di immaginare di avere tra le mani un
gomitolo eccolo qui e di dover dare una
trama al mio futuro
ancora una volta mi chiedo come posso
tessere il mio futuro se anziché un filo
dar dire un gomitolo hanno dato un
gomitolo aggrovigliato da cui non
ritrovo neanche il capo stavo ragionando
su questo punto e mi è venuto in mente
una storia un mito che certamente anche
voi conoscete lo avrete sentito a scuola
quando eravate bambini il mito di teseo
il minotauro
sono certo che anche voi conoscete la
storia di teseo solo intrappolato in un
labirinto
come mi sento anche io ora come mi sento
anch'io la mia frettolosa realtà per di
più in questo labirinto c'è un mostro in
questo labirinto c'è un mostro il
minotauro e questo mostro forse è
presente anche nella mia corsa e
dell'ansia l'ansia con cui vivo tutti i
giorni l'ansia che è benzina della corsa
a causa del mio arrivare a non capire
più nulla e proviamo a metterci nei
panni di teseo soli intrappolati in
questo labirinto senza un'arma per
abbattere il mostro senza una bussola
presentarsi senza niente se non un
gomitolo infatti teseo aveva tra le mani
il gomitolo che rihanna di aveva donato
e cosa fare in questa situazione
cosa facciamo noi di fronte ai nostri
labirinti i problemi che incontriamo
tutti i giorni con il nostro cervello
che si attorciglia come un gomitolo cosa
fare di fronte a problemi grandi come
l'inquinamento oppure problemi
siccome il buco che si sta formando
nell'ozono problemi che affliggono
l'intera umanità veri e propri labirinti
ma anche i problemi piccoli come non so
di dover riordinare la nostra scrivania
piena di fogli oppure il dover arrivare
in un posto che non conosciamo
magari senza navigatore come teseo senza
bussola con il nostro cervello che si
attorciglia piano piano come un gomitolo
con un mito lo vediamo cosa ha fatto
tesoro teseo ha sciolto l'aggrovigliata
gomito che aveva ricevuto da rihanna per
poi trovare la via d'uscita dal
labirinto facendosi guidare da un filo e
se la soluzione fosse proprio questo
filo questa guida questo filo logico se
la soluzione fosse proprio cercare la
semplicità la parola semplice deriva dal
latino simplex è letteralmente significa
piegando una volta sola ciò che è
semplice quindi non è qualcosa che si
nasconde sotto troppo pieghe né qualcosa
che superficiale che possiamo vedere la
semplicità si nasconde sotto una sola
piega della piaga dell'apparenza non lo
possiamo vedere ma ci possiamo arrivare
come ha fatto tesoro che ha trovato
un'idea semplice ma un'idea geniale
farsi guidare da un filo in filo
e allora anche noi dobbiamo trovare il
nostro filo ma come come trovare il
nostro filo in questa complessità in
questo mare di immagini che affollano la
nostra mente impegni per di più negli
uomini siamo complicati
l'uomo pensa ragiona gioisce si pente
l'uomo in un attimo si riempì di follia
poi si fa ascoltare dalla noia e per non
essere così complicato come dice dei
draghi complicare molto facile
semplificare è difficile però ho provato
a mettere insieme le parole che più mi
ricordano la semplicità e così ne è
venuto fuori il mio piccolo alfabeto il
mio alfabeto della semplicità che vorrei
condividere con voi
cominciamo lettera armonia lettera b
bellezza lettera c classicità
sono uno studente di liceo classico
frequente liceo classico da tre anni in
questi tre anni diciamo ho sbirciato
all'universo della classicità e ho visto
armonia bellezza per questo la parola
classicità enel un alfabeto
e che cos'è per me la classicità la
classicità è quell universo di miti
messaggi racconti esperienze che abbiamo
ereditato dagli antichi allora
classicità e complessità la classicità e
la situazione che più mi ricorda la
realtà complessa in cui viviamo oggi
eppure la classicità mi affascina
affacciarmi alla classicità mi spinge
voler andare oltre e guardare tutta la
piega e trovare un filo che mi guidi in
questo mondo
in questo mondo complesso quindi
affacciarsi alla classicità è un
esercizio ad andare oltre cercare sempre
la semplicità sciogliere trovare il
valore lettera v il valore dell'uomo
lettera u
e questo si fa solo sciogliendo lettera
s sciogliere come si sciogliere come
possiamo sciogliere arrivando alla
etimologia lettera e tecnologia che una
radice lettera r
il bandolo della matassa alla radice la
radice a cui dobbiamo arrivare prima di
poter declinare la parola per non
rimanere intrappolati lettera i ma
arrivare al futuro lettera f
il futuro imparando tutta questa
complessità la logica il mio filologico
lettera l logica e che cosa è la logica
la logica non è la mia cinica tabella di
marcia la mia freddissima tabella oraria
che mi permetta di essere il più
produttivo possibile no logica e il
gusto di rispettare ordine lettera e
tempi cause e conseguenze tenendo
presenti tutte le lettere che abbiamo
visto prima
quindi logica e anche gentilezza garbo
lettera g logica però è anche misura
lettera m e il no lettera n
no qualche no che devo dire per
eliminare il superfluo e per cercare
quello che mi serve la qualità lettera q
qualità
tutto questo come posso farlo
rispettando il tempo letterati va con
pazienza le terapie pazienza e poi c'è
la lettera h h e la lettera che non
pronunciamo mai nelle parole della
lettera più silenziosa
allora vorrei che in questo alfabeto
l'acqua fosse la lettera della pausa la
pausa che devo fare quando di fronte al
periodo complesso di una versione mi
perdo perdo il mio filologico quando mi
sento invaso da nomi verdi congiunzioni
proposizioni mi perdo la pausa allora
devo fare una pausa ritrovare il filo
logico di quello che sto traducendo la
pausa che devo fare io oggi per dare un
ordine ai tasselli con cui voglio
costruire il futuro dare un ordine per
una trama al filo con cui voglio essere
il futuro dare un ordine alle lettere
dell'alfabeto del futuro che prendere
fiato prendere fiato quando arriverò
alla lettera z
non sapevo come completarla lettera z ci
ho provato ho aperto il dizionario ho
cercato una parola che iniziasse con la
z ss bene nel mio alfabeto ma non l'ho
trovata perché forse del futuro non
possiamo dire tutto ci sono alcune
lettere che sarà proprio il futuro a
rivelarci mi sbaglio non alcune
tantissime il futuro cc inonderà di
nuove lettere verremo davvero davvero
inondati e cosa faremo quando verremo
inondati di novità quando ci sentiremo
bloccati in un gomitolo cosa faremo
dovremmo ricordare secondo me la lettera
più importante
ormai l'avrete capito quale lettera s
semplicità grazie
[Applauso]